justin here with a gamespot news update
after being pulled from steam due to
numerous technical issues looks like the
Dark Knight will rise again at the end
of this month posting on the game steam
page community admin Yorick said the
teams working on improving the
performance of the pc version are still
implementing fixes and tweaks with the
goal of an October re-release plan as
many of you know we released a major
patch for Batman Arkham Knight pc a few
weeks ago while there were significant
performance improvements made to the
game the teams are continuing to work on
the additional updates that were
outlined in our previous post we expect
these updates to be ready at the end of
October and which time the pc version
will be made available for purchase in
addition support for all DLC that has
been released for the console versions
will be in place batman arkham knight
was taken down from steam shortly after
its launch in june due to bugs and
graphical and performance issues in the
days following the release of Arkham
Knight on PC and the surfacing of its
numerous technical hiccups it was
revealed the port had been developed by
a small external team while principal
developer Rocksteady focused on the
console versions Rocksteady released a
statement saying would work on remedying
the port's problem and as promised a
patch addressing many of its issues has
since been released the update fixes
framerate hitches optimizes be RAM usage
improves GPU performance cleans up
textures and more no details on an exact
date yet but when we find out more we'll
be sure to let you know for more on the
Caped Crusader stay tuned to gamespot
you